good morning John and welcome to the
crash course scishow offices in Missoula
Michael Gardner's office say hello
Michael Gardner makes it all happened
this is all the 2d glasses there's the
blank yeah you get to stare at that all
the time
Liz office what's that it's a can't read
hello Katherine
hello hard at work there's a lemon bed
there too but no lemon and this is our
current project for awesome staging
table hello Blake hi danette Blake uh as
the head of editorial I'm writing about
the world's largest penguin which is now
extinct your lighting is actually really
good in here you look fantastic
oh well thanks a secret secret Easter
egg what's happening here is Nick in his
office oh no Nick is not in his there he
is
what is Nick doing measuring measure
measuring my wife gets on me for
pronouncing measuring weird that's
because you do Nick is building the new
crash course set it's beautiful it looks
really good on camera we may recognize
Nick's voice from such things as Hank
and Katherine and Michael and Nick play
Super Mario Brothers we and also his
YouTube channel the lonely director yes
which has been lonely for a while but
been a lonely place is it coming back it
is coming back just does just do like
this okay it's awesome that makes my job
a lot easier it's kind of labyrinthine
hello hi do you mind if you're on the
internet I don't learn about how dirty
that cutting board is it's gross it's
all sorts of fecal matter in there you
maybe have the best view I do this is
Peter's office oh this is Peter like
virtually and actually is a - in it it's
Peter max that is not normal it's not
normal yeah Oh gives you hard to do
while filming at the same time Oh Peter
designed this poster it's like my little
notice but Cobra and tardigrade the
tardigrade is named Milo and all things
every tardigrade
every tardigrades mileage I got this
entertainment center yeah we got an n64
no TV like it's Catherine doing our work
there it is it's my other desk it's a
family affair yeah all a family now of
closed-door to my office cuz I want to
say a few things people in this office
who have become my friends I'm very
proud of what we've done together I
think that we've created really great
things all
they have gone above and beyond and on
top of that they have offered to donate
their time shipping out items for the
project for awesome and together we're
working on some really cool new stuff
that I'll tell you about in a second but
first I want to talk about the project
for awesome because wow the IndieGoGo
campaign we raised three hundred and
ninety seven thousand dollars if you
include all of the other donations that
happen throughout the internet for
project for awesome it was more than
half a million dollars more than seven
hundred thousand comments each one of
them costing John Green a penny more
than fifteen thousand individual donors
and thousands of amazing project for
awesome videos there are so many good
causes that are going to be supported by
this so thank you all so much for
participating in whatever way you did I
am so grateful to have had the
opportunity to work with so many amazing
people on projects like the project for
awesome like lizzie bennet diaries like
scishow and crash course like dftb
records and VidCon and the truth is I
just love to create and to help people
create so a quick announcement when I
recently went to the Philip L red
zoological museum and met Emily and saw
her enthusiasm how comfortable she was
on camera the depth of her knowledge and
also got a lot of comments from people
telling me to make her have her own
youtube show we decided that we should
have her have her own YouTube show we
decided to go after it pretty
significantly so in the new year she and
Michael Aranda will be producing a new
show called the brain scoop out of that
Museum you should go check it out and
subscribe youtube.com slash the brain
scoop I'm starting to feel like my
mission in life is to create cool things
and to help people create cool things
and I'm very grateful to be working with
people who have those same goals
including you John I'll see you on
Tuesday